hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar a clinical perspective
on sexually transmitted infections what
is the state of play I am Judy O'Rourke
of laberd's and I'll be moderating this
session today's educational web seminar
is presented by lab routes the leading
scientific social networking website and
provider of virtual events and webinars
advancing scientific collaboration and
learning it's brought to you by Abbott
Molecular an Abbott we're committed to
helping people with their best possible
life through the power of Health for
more than 125 years we've brought new
products and technologies to the world
in nutrition diagnostics medical devices
and branded generic pharmaceuticals that
create more possibilities for more
people at all stages of life today
ninety-four thousand of us are working
to help people live not just longer but
better in the more than 150 countries we
serve to learn more visit WWF comm let's
get started you can post questions to
the speaker during the presentation
while they're fresh in your mind to do
so simply type them into the drop down
box located on the far left of your
screen labeled ask a question and click
on the send button questions will be
answered after the presentation to
enlarge the slide window click on the
arrows at the top right hand corner of
the presentation window if you
experience technical problems seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support tab sound at the top right
of the presentation window or report
your problem by typing it into the
answer question box located on the far
left of your screen this is an
educational webinar the saw firs free
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process of obtaining your credits I now
presented a speaker dr. John white dr.
white is a sexual health physician and
has been editor in chief of the
International Journal of STD and AIDS
since 2009 after training in Sydney
Australia he worked as a clinician and
researcher in the department of genital
urinary medicine at Guy's and st. tom
as hospitals in London for many years
until late 2017 he recently moved to
Northern Ireland and now practices at
the Ultima Galvan Hospital in
Londonderry dr. White's clinical and
research interests include bacterial SP
is sexual health for men who have sex
with men and diagnostic tests for HIV
and STI s he has a keen interest in
lymphogranuloma venereum infection and
is involved in several research studies
involving the assessment of diagnostic
tests for bacterial fbi's and HIV dr.
white will now begin his presentation
maybe thanks Judy and hello out there to
everyone thanks for joining this webinar
I've been asked to speak today about
sexually transmitted infections from a
clinical perspective which is a fairly
daunting task given the size of the
topic and it's very global scope but I
hope that during this hour I can cover
some of the major ground and share some
of my thoughts on the current challenges
that we face and particular issues of
concern in terms of disclosures I'd like
to disclose that I have received
honoraria and some research support from
various diagnostic companies in the past
few years and today's webinar has been
requested by Abbott molecular although
the content has all been put together by
myself and these are all of my own views
so by the end of this session I hope
that you're able to understand the
latest epidemiological trends for the
major st is with a focus on high-risk
groups for STI is including MSM also I'd
like to make you aware of recent
developments in diagnostic tests for STI
pathogens and particularly the
advantages of molecular assay and the
importance of the extra genital
reservoirs and hopefully you'll
appreciate the challenges of treating
bacterial STI is in an era of increasing
antimicrobial resistance this is
especially pertinent for Neisseria
gonorrhea and mycoplasma genitalium
infections
so the epidemiology of STI is you can't
really sum this up in one slide but
there are at least 30 different
organisms that can be transmitted
through a variety of different types of
sex and the most recent global estimates
from the World Health Organization that
there are annually nearly 360 million
new infections with just the four main
curable sti's those being chlamydia
gonorrhea syphilis and trichome analysis
so huge numbers that we're talking about
there and in addition over half a
billion people are infected with genital
herpes simplex virus nearly 300 million
women have a genital HPV infection and a
key point about STI is is that most of
them have no symptoms or only mild
symptoms and therefore they might not be
recognized or diagnosed or even
considered to be caused by an STI
now of course HIV and the viral
hepatitis particularly hepatitis B virus
also sexually transmitted but I've
considered them to be beyond the scope
of this presentation because it's it's
quite hard enough as it is without
having to include those
now nowhere in the world is is really
safe from sexually transmitted
infections and wherever you work I'm
sure they will be there but there are
certainly hot spots and cold spots for
each pathogen and looking back at those
four infections that I just mentioned
the majority of those bacterial
infections are seen in Africa in the
western Pacific which includes China and
both the Americas now it hasn't all been
bad news when it comes to figures and
certainly in recent decades there being
some positive developments and the two
infections chancroid which is caused by
hematologic ray I and Donovan OSIS
caused by Klebsiella granular martyrs by
the rate of both these infections have
been decreasing and now they're
considered to be quite rare in most
settings so that's really good news
and in addition as a result of human
papillomavirus vaccinations we've
observed a decrease in precancerous
lesions and in genital warts following
the rollout of HPV vaccination in those
regions and the global epidemiology of
HPV certainly looks like it's going to
change quite dramatically over the next
decade and that's great news and it goes
without mentioning they've been huge
successes globally with HIV and AIDS in
terms of its prevention and its
management but I won't discuss those
further here but nonetheless every day
millions of people continue to be
affected by sexually transmitted
infections and anyone who's ever had sex
is potentially at risk but there are
certain groups who continue to be
over-represented in prevalence and
incidence studies and these groups are
really important to access in terms of
any clinical or programmatic setting for
s T is and it's worth mentioning these
groups I mean young people and
adolescents at the time of sexual Daboo
particularly vulnerable to some
infections specific ethnic minorities
depending on where you work I'm going to
have sex with men who are referred to as
MSM for short transgendered people
people already living with HIV often
affected more by other STI s sex workers
and the clients of sex workers
geographically mobile populations
prisoners
road users of various drugs and people
who are affected by conflict and civil
unrest so you know any of those groups
that might be important to address
locally as far as ihd eye care goes now
why are STI is important well why do
they why do I do the job that I do I
suppose but in some circumstances sti's
can kill people or they can name and I
think syphilis is probably a perfect
example of this and I think we've been
very fortunate to live in an era where
syphilis has been treatable over the
last century and perhaps many of us
don't really appreciate the full scale
of syphilis morbidity and mortality that
existed in the pre-antibiotic era but
even if an infection doesn't kill you I
can certainly compromise quality of life
too many individual individuals and an
STI certainly do that in a lot of
different ways they can have adverse
effects on the sexual and reproductive
health particularly of women especially
gonorrhea and chlamydia infections many
sti's are harmful to babies and young
children and HIV is transmitted and
acquired more easily in the presence of
STI it in particular genital ulcer
diseases such as herpes and syphilis STI
is especially HPV as I mentioned risk
factors for cancer and globally there's
a huge financial impact of STI is not
only on individual but regionally and
nationally and unfortunately this is
often worst in poor countries so really
there are many reasons why I think we
need to diagnose and treat or prevent
STI s and there are many benefits to
improving sexual health in populations
now in terms of my current clinical
setting
what kind of diagnostic tests could do I
need or do I use in my clinic and in my
lab certainly routinely I would use in
clinic microscopy so not only for grand
stain but we do met wet mount
preparations and in particular dark
field microscopy for lesions that we
suspect of being caused by syphilis
routine rapid tests or point-of-care
tests that we can do in the clinic I
mean simple things like urine dip for
your analysis urine HCG testing for
pregnancy we do point-of-care testing
for HIV and then we can send tests to
our local laboratory for gonorrhea
culture trichomonas culturing Candida
culture where relevant our local
laboratory does combined chlamydia and
gonorrhea nucleic acid testing using the
Rose Kobus sa and any gonorrhea
positives that we have locally we can
confirm using the gene expert CTN GSA we
have to refer samples either to Belfast
or to London and we use those tips that
are usually in-house PCR tests for
herpes simplex type 1 & 2 for T pallidum
PCR for LGB DNA testing as well as
microplane plasma genitalium testing and
resistance testing for mycoplasma
genitalium and local ER serology we
usually test using enzyme immunoassay
for HIV hepatitis B and C and syphilis
any syphilis that is positive we also
then subsequently test using t PHA and
our PR
okay so now focusing on the specific
sti's perhaps let's start with gonorrhea
and this is caused by the organism
Neisseria gonorrhea which is
gram-negative bacterium classically
causes lower genital tract infection in
men and women and that can subsequently
be complicated by ascending infection to
cause salpingitis and PID in women and
if I did immitis in men gonorrhea can
occur in the rectum and the throat and
these are the major sites of infection
in MSM although women can also be
affected in this road and the rectum and
indeed some heterosexual men that we see
also are infected with throat gonorrhea
women can pass this infection onto
neonates during birth and anybody who
has a mucosal infection with gonorrhea
really it can spread to the blood and
then often onwards to the joints and
other organs really in the body can be
affected by gonorrhea rare but a very
severe infection indeed and the eye is
one placement you really don't want
gonorrhea as it can cause a really
severe conjunctivitis both in neonates
and in adults and this can result in
permanent corneal damage
rated gonorrhea will vary according to
the region that you're working in but
these are some recent figures from
England where we have very good
surveillance of STI s and they probably
typical of many Western settings where
we've seen an increase in the numbers of
gonorrhea infections over time and that
graph shows a very disproportionate rate
of infection among men and what this
represents is a significant burden of
gonorrhea infection in MSM and I'm not
sure if that reflects what you're seeing
locally but there's certainly been an
increase in in gonorrhea in many
settings in the last decade now in much
of the world diagnosing gonorrhea is
done clinically or syndromic Lee but if
you have a microscope this is still a
very good test for seeing the typical
gram-negative intracellular diplococci
in an inflammatory discharge but in
reality it's really only a sensitive
test in men with symptomatic gonorrhea
urethritis but nonetheless it's still a
very quick cheap and a useful test and I
use it every day in clinic but culture
has been the main way of achieving a
definitive diagnosis of gonorrhea for
many years and it also has the advantage
of enabling the determination of
antimicrobial resistance on the plate
and this is really important to this
organism the nucleic acid amplification
test which I'll refer to as gnats have
become the new gold standard in the last
decade for certainly sensitivity as far
as detecting gonorrhea goes and they're
now the primary tests that we used for
detecting gonorrhea in most world
resource settings
now DC Nets have evolved to be both
highly sensitive and mostly very
specific although some individual assays
can still generate false positives if
they detect other commenced on Neisseria
organisms which are often present
particularly in the throat and so most
labs will need to have alternate a days
to confirm any initial GC net positive
results particularly if they've come
from areas such as a throat or the
rectum but in general nets are great
because they're much more forgiving
regarding storage and transport
conditions for specimens and this is
really enabled sampling to be done in a
much wider range of settings such as
outreach or remote clinics rather than a
clinic that's right next to a big
laboratory which will often need for
culture another big advantage of juicy
Nets is that they've enabled us to
develop the use of less invasive
specimens such as urine and silk
collected vulva vaginal swabs where is
still for culture if we want a GC
culture taken we have to take their
painful URI tour squab for men and in
those survival swabs from women these
are really uncomfortable for patients
and they're quite resource intensive to
collect so self collection and home
sampling of both innovative ways that
these tests are now being used it's not
all good about GC nets the downside is
that traditionally they don't really
give us anything but a positive or a
negative result so we don't get any
information on whether the organism is
still liable dead and that can be
important if you're testing somebody not
long after they've been treated in
addition we don't know whether there's
any Ana microbial resistance presence
and this is really crucial in the
current era there are some new net
essays that are emerging that can also
detect markers of resistance or
sensitivity to antibiotics and this can
be helpful if that as a result we're not
only we know that Connery is there but
we know that this is a strain of
gonorrhea that will respond to a
particular drugs and this has been used
especially for quinolone drugs in recent
years and tests like this are going to
be vital going forward particularly
where culture results are unavailable
and one such essay that's recently come
to the market is tests
Australia the speed ex test in terms of
the GC culture that GC RIT Nets have
really come into their own when testing
MSM now most MSM have gonorrhea
infection that's usually extra genital
and it's usually asymptomatic and here's
a big study that we did in London nearly
ten years ago now and we looked at over
4,000 MSM attending our services and
when we tested everyone using Nets at
those three sites we found that the
rates of gonorrhea were much higher at
the throat and rectum they were in the
urethra and most of these are
asymptomatic and even when you compared
paired samples where we talk cultures
from all these sites as well
culture was still a good test to the
urethra but when you look at the rectal
site we were only able to culture about
half of the infections that were present
in the rectum and when it came to the
throat about only one in five NSM were
able to have a positive culture from the
throat and so in this cohort had we just
tested with culture we would have missed
more than half of the gonorrhea and
these men would have gone undiagnosed
and untreated now given that these
results more or less mandate the use of
GC nets for testing MSM at all three
sites the use of three separate samples
per patient is quite expensive and we
did a study in London looking at the use
of pooled samples from the throat and
rectum and urine and combining into one
sample for analysis and this was
published in JCM in 2016 and our results
as well as those of other investigators
whose since replicated this work have
found that the pooled sample performs
well in MSM as well as in women and
going forward this may be a much less
expensive way to screen effectively for
not only gonorrhea but familiar as well
and whilst a positive result might not
always indicate which of the mucosal
sites were infected in practice we found
that provided we treat the patient we
rarely find it in terms of clinical
significance but clearly that the tests
don't have a claim or a license for this
at the moment so it really does depend
on your local setting and what you're at
able to do with you on that testing as
far as rapid tesco well there are
repetetive ailable for gonorrhea because
that we whilst using that's and culture
are great the results usually take days
to appear and that doesn't always help
the patient that's in clinic with you
today and the Gram stain is the original
rapid test and as I've mentioned it's
still a good test but really only for
male urethra and it lacks sensitivity
and specificity in other sites our
antigen based tests have appeared in
recent years for gonorrhea but their
performance has been very disappointing
and none can yet be recommended for
routine use more recently rapid net
based assays of emerged and these
certainly have the potential to improve
clinical pathways for gonorrhea
especially in settings where lab results
can take sometimes weeks to get back to
the clinic or you might have patients
who might not be able to return easily
for treatment there's various companies
that have tests they're available now or
imminently be available and I've listed
some of these here the time two results
varies depending on the platform from
maybe five to ten minutes up to ninety
minutes and some cases to take 90
minutes might not be considered to be
particularly rapid but certainly these
have the potential to improve syndromic
management algorithms and enable much
better antibiotic stewardship
particularly in settings where over
treatment is currently common but in the
UK settings where assays like this have
been used the same day results that have
been available have been really popular
with patients and they've certainly
enabled a significant reduction in the
time from test treatment when it's
occurred and why is anybody stewardship
important for gonorrhea well it's become
a superbug in recent years and if you're
not aware since antibiotics were
invented gonorrhea has always had the
ability to evolve into a new strain
that's been able to evade cure with the
antibiotic at the time and as you can
see from this graphic we're now starting
to run out of drug classes to treat
gonorrhea effectively
super gonorrhea as you can see there
it's of course it's all over the news
and and this is a report just from the
BBC news last week where there was
another couple of cases of extensively
drug resistant gonorrhea that were
isolated into women in the UK now it's
likely they're required outside of the
country but it does suggest that we're
going to be seeing this more commonly
now kept track zone resistance has been
increasingly prevalent in the Far East
over the last decade and it does seem
that it's about to move this way and in
the last few years they've been several
treatment failures that have been
described with the first-line dual
therapy of kept track zone Enders
extreme Iceland so people are really
starting to panic because they are
really now well-founded concerns about
untreatable gonorrhea now how do we
treat gonorrhea well currently most GC
management guidelines worldwide
recommend dual treatment with varying
doses of kept track zone and
azithromycin together and the the
various doses probably reflect the lack
of clear evidence about what the best
regimen really is now unfortunately as
this room Ison is becoming increasingly
resistant quite quickly and that has
rendered dual therapy less effective and
now that there are cases of kept track
zone resistance as well we're really not
sure which drug to go to next looking
across the surveillance in Europe these
the latest figures from 2016 which
showed that there were no kept track
zone resistant isolates that had
occurred but clearly in 2018 and 2019
there have been a few reported now not
so far is it from Iceland there where
across-the-board resistance was seen on
average in 7.5% of settings but that has
been increasing quite significantly in
the same certainly been seen in the US
and in other parts of the world
in the UK we have very good surveillance
of gonorrhea resistance and looking here
you can see here quite a sharp jump in
as interim ice and resistance in 2015
and 2016 and that has continued and some
of those items have been highly
resistant to as this from Iceland
so what do we do in terms of treating
gonorrhea well all is not lost a high
proportion of gonorrhea isolates are
still very sensitive to the old drugs
that we've used for gonorrhea so if we
actually know that an organism is
sensitive we can still use a drug like
ciprofloxacin which is actually a really
good drug for gonorrhea and probably
two-thirds of our gonorrhea that we see
in the UK you could still use
superblocks as an upfront if you knew
the the bug was sensitive to it other
old drugs like gentamicin and spectrum
ice and still have excellent efficacy
against gonorrhea strains but
unfortunately they're not so effective
for throat infections irrespective of
the resistance patterns and that does
limit their use somewhat particularly in
MSM now there are some newer drugs that
still have 100% efficacy against all
gonorrhea strains seems so far that
further work is needed to guide optimal
dosing of these and whether or not they
will be best used as a single agent or
inderal richman so drugs I go to pin em
so literal niacin and two new drugs that
have been in the pipeline for a while to
code a dayson and Zoli FLOTUS and and
they've all undergone clinical trials
for gonorrhea in recent years some
interesting work being done in Melbourne
looking at antiseptic mouthwash to see
whether it can prevent throat gonorrhea
in innocent and it would be great if
that does work and also some preliminary
data suggest that we need to couple
vaccinations off with some cross
protection against gonorrhea so further
trials of vaccinations are awaited
because that would be a fantastic way of
controlling gonorrhea infection that's
not over gonorrhea what about syphilis
well unfortunately this old foe is still
endemic in many areas of the world and
despite declining rates in the late 20th
century it reimbursed in Western
settings over the last 20 years or so in
men have sex with men and now it's an
infection that we're seeing every day in
this population and sadly the scourge of
congenital syphilis is once again being
seen in the USA and in the UK although
the highest population rates are still
seen in Africa and South America and
those figures there from the World
Health Organization which show this
enormous
number of preventable fetal neonatal and
infant deaths that are really quite
staggering considering how easy syphilis
is to test and and treat by our
standards looking at this graph you can
see there's those part of the world
where congenital syphilis are still a
daily occurrence and certainly much more
workers needs in this regard locally in
the UK this graph captured captures our
own experience with early syphilis
diagnosis recently where there's been a
low but steady number of cases occurring
in women an ever-increasing number of
cases occurring in men and these are
mostly MSM and perhaps this is the same
experience for many of you who are
listening today
of course syphilis still does what it
does best and that's to imitate us about
any other disease and so it continues to
show up all over the hospital and in
particular in in the last decade there's
been a sharp increase in ocular syphilis
that's been seen in many different
settings in Europe in the US where the
MSM epidemics in syphilis have occurred
now fortunately good old penicillin
maintains its activity against syphilis
and it's still our first-line treatment
for this infection so weekly injections
and bender themes for uncomplicated
infection although for neurological or
ocular disease we have to resort to
using daily intramuscular injections of
protein penicillin or intravenous a Cris
can determine for treating these
manifestations we have seen that most of
the local strains of syphilis that are
circulating among MSM have been selected
out over the last couple of decades to
be resistant to macrolides which is a
shame because as it or Mason has been
able to be used to treat syphilis in
areas such as Africa but fortunately
doxycycline remains a very useful
second-line therapy where penicillin
can't be used the big threat with
penicillin is that the very real
possibility of stock-outs
of long-acting penicillin benzathine
penicillin and this it has occurred in
our first world settings as well as in
resource-poor settings and it really
threatens our ability to manage this
disease so we need much more benzathine
now in terms of the diagnosis of
syphilis well it has evolved and yet
we're still relying on hundred year old
tests in many settings to diagnose
syphilis dark field microscopy it's a
disappearing skill but those of us who
can still remember how to do it it find
it a useful test but it's really only if
you've got lesions that are present in
patients and a good microscope and even
in the best hand that sensitivity is
probably only about 70% or less in
recent years the use of PCR to detect
specific Trevin IVA pallidum DNA has
been successful but unfortunately is not
yet a commercially available test and so
few of us have access to that test PCR
has been used on blood as well but it's
sensitivity in most settings is quite
Oh for histopathology Starboard's
thought to contain syphilis there is an
immuno histo chemistry staying the
spirochetes that has helped pathologists
to diagnose syphilis but of course you
need biopsy tissue Phineas and you also
have to think of the diagnosis first but
it's worth alerting you histopathology
x' colleagues to this test if they're
not aware of it
theological tests remain the mainstay of
screening for syphilis and some of the
older tests such as the FTA absorption
method have given way to the more
automated essay such as EIA
for the detection of specific trip animo
pallidum antibodies their force
positives do occur with the EIA test and
so we still need to use the more
specific essay such as tpha or TPPA and
they're essential for confirming
syphilis and of course we still rely on
the nonspecific cardiolipin antibody
tests such as the RPI of the VDRL to
monitor disease activity response to
treatment and also to detect reinfection
in people who previously had syphilis
infection
now some attempts had been made to
automate these non trip animal tests in
recent years but this been done with
limited success so I'm sure every lab is
probably still familiar with the
macroscopic RP our cards that you can
see there on the slide or the use of
VDRL slides for the microscope
now one important breakthrough in the
last decade has been the use of rapid
syphilis point-of-care tests and these
simple lateral flow assays can detect
specific tripping evil antibodies and a
few of them have also been enabled with
a nonspecific antibody component
component although those with a
nonspecific component aren't necessarily
more effective in some settings where
over treatment of syphilis is common
regardless of what tests you use but
these tests are easy to use they're
inexpensive inexpensive and in some of
the tests they've been incorporated as
dual HIV and syphilis antibody tests and
this is especially important in
antenatal settings where HIV infections
in their notes can be prevented with the
use of these simple tests and where
they've been used and assessed in the
field there are some drawbacks of both
under diagnosis and over diagnosis but
over treating for syphilis in these
types of programs are generally
acceptable given the lethality of the
disease especially its effect on babies
now what about chlamydia trachomatis
genital chlamydia is a really high
equivalent in infection in most
populations globally and typically it
affects adolescents and young adults
although it tends to be seen more across
the aged reign in MSM and it occurs much
more as a rectal rather than a genital
infection in them
recent studies have shown high rates of
rectal infection in young women as well
and rectal infection in women might be
an important factor both in treatment
response and the ability of chlamydia to
persist and you'll see more research
being done on this important area as
time goes on that PID and women remains
the biggest problem caused by chlamydia
along with everything - in men but even
following successful treatment of PID
the adverse outcomes that are seen in
women such as ectopic pregnancy tubal
factor infertility and chronic pelvic
pain do result in much more bility and
they're very expensive to manage in most
settings neonatal I and lung disease can
result from untreated chlamydia
infection in pregnant women as well this
graphs from the surveillance of
chlamydia in England in 2017 shows the
typical age peaks of chlamydia in the
late teens and early 20s and strain it
screening programs for chlamydia in
these age groups have been recommended
and they have been implemented in places
like the UK as far as diagnosing
chlamydia whilst culture for chlamydia
used to be used extensively for testing
it's really done these days and has been
superseded by chlamydia naps and in most
settings that's what is is used to
diagnose chlamydia rapid Nets are
starting to appear sadly some of the non
amplified rapid tests that were
developed have performed very poorly for
chlamydia and can't be recommended
we prefer non-invasive specimens for
testing for chlamydia these days so
urine in men involve a vagina swabs in
women rectal swabs in men who have sex
with men and in women and these are
indicated from recent studies even when
no anal sex is reported because they do
have an increased pick up rate for
chlamydia in women dr. cycling and
azithromycin are both still effective
for chlamydial infection as no pre
resistance has been reported in
chlamydia
many recent studies do suggest that a
step one gram dose of azithromycin might
be less effective and it's especially
for rectal infection and doxycycline is
preferred in this situation and it
probably also works better for
symptomatic male you retool infection as
well the basic reused doxycycline
first-line but all chlamydia infections
unless it's contraindicated and some
guidelines are starting to reflect this
as well and once again in MSM if you're
not testing extra general sites for
chlamydia you're missing the majority of
it and you can see here from these
figures from that same study that we did
in London the rectum is by far the most
commonly affected site with chlamydia in
MSM now lymphoid granulometry Nerium or
LGV is chlamydia as well but just not as
we know it
generally it's caused by the the l0 bars
of chlamydia and these infect lymphoid
cells rather than mucosal cells and thus
they can produce a tissue invasive
infection with much more severe clinical
features such as genital ulcer disease
and lymph node disease that can cause
buboes and scarring now traditionally
this is seen mostly in the tropics where
it still occurs and it's usually managed
syndromic Lee in these settings however
LGB whilst historically had been seen in
MSM as recently as the 1980s it more or
less disappeared but around 15 years ago
it was detected once again in Europe and
it's once again become endemic in the
MSM population where it occurs mostly as
a rectal infection and it's most likely
to be symptomatic as a severe
hemorrhagic proctitis it's strongly
linked with hiv-positive and Hep C
positive populations and with those MSM
who engage in CHEM sex but you know it's
an infection that can be seen across the
board in MSM symptoms are often so
severe that it can be confused with
inflammatory bowel disease and delayed
diagnosis of LGB is likely if patients
are seen outside of a sexual health
setting and STI testing is not offered
some recent large European studies have
shown that LGB can actually be carried
asymptomatic Lee in up to 30 percent of
rectal infections in MSM and this is
probably key to its persistence
now LGB can only be confirmed by the
detection of one of the old serovars of
Chlamydia trachomatis now all chlamydia
Nets should be positive in LGB
containing specimens but you do need to
do an additional specific LGV DNA test
if you want to prove that it's LGV and
unfortunately there's no licensed
commercial essay for this and so in most
settings this will be done with the use
of an in-house essay or referral for a
reference lab test the main difference
with the management of LGB is that
longer causes of doxycycline recommended
although we have published recently that
as long as you use at least seven days
of doxycycline in most cases you're
probably going to clear the infection
and here's just a graph that shows the
numbers of cases over time since 2003 in
the UK and clearly this is an infection
that continues to persist and increase
in recent years all recent cases of
being in MSM and most of them have been
HIV positive and other European
countries have seen very similar
patterns of infection moving from LGB to
trichomonas vaginalis and this is the
most common curable STI globally but
most of it actually occurs in
resource-poor settings we do see tracker
motifs in Europe and in the UK and but
mostly in our own settings that seem
very clustered in specific populations
and for instance in the UK and
particularly in South London where I
used to work we saw TV every day but it
was much much more prevalent in the
Black Caribbean population and also
somewhat in the black African population
it also tended to occur in older age
groups than the other bacterial STI s
and it was often asymptomatic and whilst
it's really associated with any really
serious direct adverse outcomes it is a
major cofactor for HIV transmission and
it also has a strong population effect
on reproductive health in women so it is
an important infection
I was diagnosing TV most of it is seen
in resource-poor settings and acids
managed syndromic li but microscopy is a
simple and cheap test that is quite
effective but its sensitivity is low
compared to the more modern tests but
sensitivity is up to about 70 75 percent
in symptomatic women where it's done on
a fresh sample and it's still a test
that we use in clinic and find useful
but just because the the wet mount is
negative doesn't exclude trachomatis
infections so having another test for
certain populations is important culture
is often done but it's quite resource
intensive there is a new rapid antigen
based test the awesome test which
certainly seems has very good
sensitivity and it's quick and easy to
use and has being used successfully in
many sort of non lab settings but it's
great to see that TV nets are now
available on some of the commercial
platform now these tests have the
highest sensitivity and they can also be
used on the same samples as the CT GC
net and can even be multiplex with these
assays so recent studies have shown
poorer clearance rates with
metronidazole treatment especially the
two grams stat dose and week long causes
of metronidazole are now recommended you
can also use tinidazole which is
probably a bit better but there are a
few other reliable antimicrobials for
trichomonas and certainly more study
with newer agents are needed for this
very prevalent infection globally
now mycoplasma genitalium is another bug
if you haven't heard of it before it has
been hitting the headlines recently and
it's also now purported to be one of
these superbugs now M genitalium is a
proven cause of non gonococcal
urethritis in men as strong associative
associations with cervicitis and with
PID and women but only recently have
commercial essays become available for M
genitalium so there's still a lot much
testing going on but wherever studies
have been done anywhere in the world in
genitalium is usually proved to be a
prevalent organism in sexually active
populations and it seems to have similar
risk factors and similar rates to
chlamydia trachomatis infection
genitally the big problem is that its
sensitivity to available antibiotics is
falling rapidly and the fear is that
soon it might become untreatable now
that's the only reliable way of
diagnosing mycoplasma genitalium and in
addition to a net result for optimal
management we may also end up requiring
molecular analysis to look for
resistance associated mutations because
these can help to predict which drugs
will be effective from mg/l Italian and
unfortunately the most recent studies
that we look at show that at least 50%
of strains are resistant to macrolides
and we used to rely on is this from
Iceland to treat my class and genitalia
but unfortunately it's unlikely to work
in many settings now and the only other
drug that was reliable was moxifloxacin
but now at least 10% of strains in these
settings are now resistant to these
quinolone drugs and so we're really
wondering where we're going to go next
I mean doxycycline does work for
microwaves and genitalia but probably
only in about 1/3 of cases and there are
really few other drugs with proven
efficacy so watch this space that the
future does look a little bit grim
genitalium the herpes simplex 1 and 2
infections have always been highly
prevalent viruses and HSV two is usually
been responsible for most symptomatic
genital herpes disease but in recent
decades in many settings there's been a
big shift towards age
the one causing the initial episode
burpees in young people and seemingly as
as due to a fall in childhood infection
with herpes simplex type 1 so fewer
people have cold sores and therefore
they are more susceptible to getting
herpes elsewhere on their bodies now in
lo our local setting here in Northern
Ireland when we reviewed it recently
about 80% of our initial episode genital
herpes Places test positive for HSV one
rather than HSV - unfortunately HSV one
of the much less recurrent infection
than genital HSV - so perhaps it's not
such a bad thing but testing for herpes
does rely on type specific
herpes gnats and these are much more
sensitive than culture and there's
several commercial assays that are now
available in resource-poor settings
syndromic management of genital ulcer
disease does need to cover herpeses this
is an increasingly common cause of
general ulcers especially since other
causes like chancroid have been falling
acyclovir and related drugs ballet cycle
in Fahrenheit severe is still the main
treatments used but disappointingly we
still await an effective herpes simplex
vaccine
now human papillomavirus or HPV is
probably the most prevalent STI globally
and many of the more than 150 strains of
HPV are transmissible sexually and
genital warts as well as some anal
genital than other cancers are caused by
HPV oncogenic strains now most HPV is
asymptomatic and warts whilst they're
not particularly dangerous when they do
occur they do cause much morbidity in
adults and particularly psychosexual
impact on on particularly young adults
is something that we continue to see
there's or of course continues to be an
enormous global cancer burden from the
oncogenic strains of HPV especially type
16 and 18 but in the last decade there's
been major successes that have been seen
with the use of HPV vaccination and not
just for the high-grade precancerous
lesions and cancers but also for genital
warts where the quadrivalent vaccination
is being used and it's now a high
priority to roll out this vaccination to
all those populations still at risk the
newest version of the vaccination is now
non available is even greater protection
against a wider range of the oncogenic
strains of HPV
now just looking at diagnostic testing
overall I mean it's important to think
of it in terms of the two parts of the
world in resource-poor settings
depending on the feeling that the
opportunity to actually diagnose this
sti's might be completely absent due to
the lack of skills of lack of diagnostic
equipment and so many many patients and
manage syndrome eclis and unfortunately
many of these syndromic algorithms have
very poor specificity and the high rates
of asymptomatic sti's mean that a huge
burden of disease is simply never
detected or treated as is very little
screening available one of the problems
is also that in many regions of the
world over-the-counter consultations in
pharmacies or in markets and provision
of antibiotic treatments are common and
this often results in mismanagement and
very poor antibiotic stewardship and I'm
sure that decades of this practice have
likely produced some of the extensively
drug-resistant organisms that we're
currently facing that I've discussed a
point-of-care test for HIV and syphilis
have certainly already been implemented
with much success in resource-poor
settings and other point-of-care tests
are emerging and we really look forward
to the use of some of these other rapid
tests in this setting
but a quote from w-h-o in a recent
report that points out that a major
barrier to advancing STI control and
prevention is the lack of reliable
low-cost point-of-care tests I think
that really encapsulates one of the big
problems in resource-poor settings but
in resource-rich settings in our part of
the world's we're very fortunate to have
access to a variety of modern
Diagnostics and many of them are now
molecular essays as molecular tests
start to take over some of the more
traditional methodologies but culture
still remains very important and
particularly in gonorrhea for
antimicrobial resistance surveillance
and for the management of individual
patients but better essays and research
has enabled us to use non-invasive
sampling and self sampling in settings
remote from the clinic and this has
certainly helped to modernize many
pathways for STI care and expand access
to screening clinical pathways that
continue to be improved by shorter
turnaround time for results and now the
emergence of rapid tests certainly has
potential to enhance our local clinical
services as well in the resource risk
setting not not just in the resource
poor settings we're also beginning to
see clinic based labs state spaces
expanding so the sort of removal of the
gap between the lab and the clinic and
as well increasing use of multiplex
essays is starting to make life easier
and innovations like pooling as I've
mentioned before can also help us to use
these essays in more affordable ways in
the future I think molecular microbial
resistance testing will be of increasing
importance for some infections and we
need to continue to work with the test
manufacturers in this regard
now I did want to add just a couple of
slides just to discuss some key related
conditions
first of all in women genital pimples
can be related to common conditions such
as bacterial vaginosis Candida and to a
lesser extent aerobic vaginitis now
whilst they're not considered to be
classical sti's although you can argue
that bacterial vaginosis probably is an
STI they do occur commonly in women who
are sexually active and they could
contribute substantially to quality of
life issues for women in resource-poor
settings they also impact really
significantly on the syndromic
management algorithms
particularly for things like the general
discharge and specific diagnostic
solutions are required in all settings
for these conditions in addition the
population effects of bacterial
vaginosis on HIV transmission and the
reproductive health outcomes in women
are really substantial and the journal
dysbiosis I think is every bit as
important as STI is at this global
population level and in the future I
hope there are even better diagnostic
and management solutions for this in
addition many had sex with men remain
one of the key population in in all
regions of the world when it comes to
sti's and thus endemics of HIV sexually
transmitted infections and recreational
drug use a really complex and the
interplay of these needs to be
recognized when managing MSM in the
clinical setting the impact of pre
exposure prophylaxis or prep for HIV
will also be substantial now not only
because it will almost certainly reduce
the incidence of HIV in various
populations but it does have the
potential I think particularly in MSM
for changes in sexual behavior that
savor a rise in the incidence of other
STRs and that's something that many
clinical services that see MSM on prep
have actually become to see so in a way
it's probably the perfect storm for some
of the problems with sti's and
resistance however as I've mentioned
before MSM have multiple potential sites
for sti's and in practice we often see
multiple concurrent STI is in the same
page
an in addition we see extra organisms
such as gastrointestinal pathogens
behaving in it as STRs and MSM and
Shigella and hepatitis A are two
examples of such and this all creates a
lot of clinical complexity and in many
settings that this may warrant
additional training to staff and
additional resources in order to
optimally manage MSM and also managing
MSM with recurrent bacterial sti's on a
background of increasing resistance
means the good antibiotic stewardship is
really critical and I think there needs
to be much greater attention to this
internationally so in summary that was a
bit of a whirlwind tour of some of the
issues surrounding STI is in the current
clinical environment certainly from my
perspective and things that I see my
colleagues dealing with and clearly
SBI's continue to impact global health
in a big way it's not just the same old
foes such as syphilis and gonorrhea but
their newer pathogens like mycoplasma
genitalium which are creating additional
challenges as organisms become resistant
to current antibiotics we need to find
new strategies to manage bacterial
infections and try hard to preserve the
precious drugs that we still have
available to us by the stricter and more
prudent use of these drugs and this is
Express especially a challenge for
resource poor settings as I mentioned
but even in our own setting with all of
the modern tests and the laboratory and
all of the treatments we have to hand
STI rates are still increasing so it's
evident that new approaches are required
so new tests new treatments innovation
and in particular I think we need to
engage effectively those very risk
groups that are the ones that we're
seeing most commonly and if we do that I
think this will be key to success in
managing STI is going forward but that's
enough for me I'd certainly like to open
it up to the floor and see if there are
any questions or comments and I'll hand
back to the moderate moderator thanks
Judy
thank you doctor
in tation a quick reminder for our
audience on how to submit questions
simply type them into the drop down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window labeled ask a
question and click on the send button
dr. white will answer as many questions
as time permits the first question is
there are a lot of collection devices
specific to the anatomical site for each
bug how difficult is to manage at your
clinic and what recommendations or
changes would you like to see in this
area
thanks Judy that's an important question
and I think it really will vary
according to where you're working and
what essays you're using both in the
laboratory and just locally in clinic
certainly there's been a move towards
some multi collection devices in some of
the commercial assays in recent years
and I think this is really helpful to
have one swab that can be used for an
endo sir vehicle or above a vulva
vaginal specimen and to be able to use
that same surah rectal swab or a throat
swab I think makes life a lot easier
rather than fumbling around with
different swabs trying to find the right
one the going forward I think that
commercial essays especially when
they're multiplexing and testing for
multiple different pathogens in the one
essay this enables us to use the single
specimen rather than taking a lot of
different tests to test for the
different organisms the and similarly if
you're using urine as a specimen being
able to use that or to protect a pet the
urine into the same tube for analysis I
think that makes life easier but yeah I
think that for some people if they're
having to test four five or six
different things in the one patient
sometimes they might still be forced to
take five or six different specimens
until there's one test that really
enables us to test everything in the one
specimen
thank you how could molecular
diagnostics testing help improve your
clinical treatment decisions
well I think we've been seeing the the
impact of molecular diagnostics
improving our clinical care of patients
for many years now and you know with
with probably the first nucleic acid
tests that we use widely was the
chlamydia test and and I think once we
started to use chlamydial Nets we
realized just how much chlamydia we were
missing using some of the much less
sensitive tests and some of those tests
had specificity issues as well and so
you know we could be a lot more certain
when we were treating people for
chlamydia that the people truly had the
infection and that we weren't missing
any infections and I think that the same
still holds today you know if you're
using culture to test for gonorrhea only
I think that as I've sort of pointed out
in some of those slides you're missing a
lot of infection protect potentially and
really to detect as much infection as
possible you know the molecular essays
are going to enable us to to do that
because a lot of patients they don't
want to be diagnosed with something they
really want to be told that they don't
have anything and to be able to really
reassure patients particularly those who
might come in as advised for a an STI
screen our ability to be able to say
look you've got the all clear it really
depends on the sensitivity of the essays
that we use and molecular sa certainly
have the best sensitivity in that regard
and then when you're looking at an
organisms like my plasma genitalium
there really are no other options apart
from you know treating people syndrome
eclis and when you diagnose a male with
your risers it's if you don't know
whether it's mycoplasma genitalium
giving the appropriate treatment these
days is just becoming increasingly
difficult so yeah I think that there's
still an important role for a lot of
those other tests but molecular tests
are really making our life easier but
they're also improving the outcomes for
patients and giving the patients what
they want really which sometimes is just
to be told they don't have anything
thank you we're getting so many great
questions coming in the next one is if a
patient is positive for chlamydia but
negative for gonorrhea using that would
you treat for both kept track zone I'm
sorry would you treat for both for
example include kept track zone I am or
only for chlamydia
but it's a really pertinent question
because I think that the the use of
really important antibiotics like kept
track so and I think that whilst we've
been throwing this drug around for
decades and it's still very useful to
treat a wide range of non sexually
transmitted infections as well in the
STI setting we really want to only be
using kept track zone for people who we
know have a gonococcal infection and not
treating people who don't have the
infection and bear in mind a lot of
people who don't have the infection they
may still be at high future risk of
gonorrhea and therefore by exposing them
to antibiotics that have important
activity against gonorrhea we may be
actually doing those patients a
disservice by enabling them to develop
resistance to those drugs in other
commensal organisms which then could be
transferred to gonorrhea if they do
become infected at a later date and so I
think the stewardship of only using
drugs like kept track zone for patients
where there's a really strong indication
for it is what we should all be aiming
for but clearly we've had a very
defensive prescribing practice for many
years now because either because we
don't have the test to be able to
confidently exclude the infection or
because a patient may present as a
contact of gonorrhea so they've had sex
with someone who has had gonorrhea
diagnosed but we don't know they've got
gonorrhea or not unless there's clinical
signs we have to wait to those
laboratories results and those results
sometimes can take weeks to return to
having more rapid turnaround time for
results can enable us to more easily
defer treatment and reserve it for only
those people who are infected so at
least in our settings I think we need to
move away from this syndrome ik
algorithm where you think look someone's
got to discharge or someone's got some
symptoms it could be this so let's let's
throw everything but the kitchen sink at
them I think that we need to try to be
really specific about the antibiotic
treatments we use
thank you next one is how big is the
problem with mats if you retest too soon
and how soon is too soon and then
secondarily how does this vary with
sites of infection great questions and
not a lot of evidence to really answer
them in practice yes of course you can
test too soon and and if somebody has
been treated for an infection
for instance gonorrhea if they were
given an injection for gonorrhea
yesterday we really shouldn't be able to
detect gonorrhea today by culture if the
treatments been effective it's pretty
quick to be able to kill gonorrhea and
of course once the once the organism is
dead it it can't culture but we can
still detect the organism the following
day by the use of a net and so several
days afterwards the nucleic acid can
persist I've seen it in individual
patients where they've tested positive
with the GC net at 2 weeks after they've
been treated and then several days later
repeated the test and it subsequently
become negative
most guidelines will say for gonorrhea
and particularly chlamydia where there's
a bit more experience that after 2 weeks
it's probably a reasonable time to be
able to test and if the test is still
positive after 2 weeks it probably
suggests that they have a persistent or
recurrent infection but really the the
evidence base out there doesn't include
large studies they're usually only
relatively small studies but certainly
repeating and that test within a week of
treatment is probably too soon in most
settings because interpreting a positive
result in that setting is really going
to be difficult certainly if it's
negative it's reassuring but yeah I
think we need more studies for that as
far as other sites of infection I mean
most of the studies that have been done
have looked at genital sites in men and
women we've had some clinical experience
with rectal and throat infections and
certainly in the throat as I said that
one of those cases I was alluding to was
a throat infection and that it seemed
that there was still GC RNA detectable
after 2 weeks that subsequently became
negative without treatment
but then sometimes throat infections
clear without treatment anyway so yeah I
mean that's just my experience I don't
think there's any studies to really say
with any degree of certainty but more
works needed thank you next one is how
effective how effective are treatment
options we have from multiple sexually
transmitted infections in a given
patient
um I suppose if you break it down by
organism I mean weak you know in in
clinics despite the threat of gonorrhea
resistance here in in Europe and in the
UK I mean I we're pretty close to 100
percent effective if we're using kept
track zone and and the UK guidelines
changes that are pending or more or less
been drafted and implemented in the last
few months in in the UK where we're now
treating gonorrhea with kept track zone
one gram as a single dose without any
azithromycin code treatment and our
experience on thousands of patients in
recent years in London is that where we
we've only used kept track zone to treat
gonorrhea it's been pretty much 100
percent effective because we haven't yet
been seeing any kept track sign
resistant now that will change once we
start to see more and more important
cases of resistance but if you're
working in the Far East your clearance
rate of gonorrhea with any dose of kept
track zone is probably going to be lower
chlamydia I think that you're looking at
still very good rates of clearance of
genital chlamydia infections probably
close to a hundred percent if you're
using a week of doxycycline if you're
using a 1 gram stat doses azithromycin
that might drop down to ninety
ninety-five percent for genital
infections and lower for rectal
infections whereas a week of doxycycline
still seems to work very well for
infections at all sites trichomonas is a
big problem i think in terms of
treatment success i think there's always
been this assumption that i if some of
the primers you just give metronidazole
and if they if it doesn't go away
they've been reinfected but in recent
years has become very clear that
treatment failure occurs quite readily
and we've got some data from from london
that suggested that the treatment
efficacy might be somewhere only between
eighty eighty-five percent and it seems
to be lower if a single dose of
metronidazole is used compared to a five
to seven day course of metronidazole so
longer causes of metronidazole are now
recommended but there's some cases and
we've all seen cases where no amount of
metronidazole or tanida's all will clear
these trichomonas infections and there
aren't many other effective agents we're
having to resort to things like butt
boric acid preparations and other not so
readily available treatments so I think
that there's for such a common infection
there's a lot more work that's needed
there
herpes pretty much exactly we still seem
to work on all herpes in immunocompetent
individuals and yeah I think for other
infections I mean as there are specific
issues but they're the main ones I think
thank you are you seeing an increase in
Home Collection devices in Europe and
what are some of the challenges
associated with Home Collection if any
yeah I think that there's a number of
programs now that are looking at sort of
postal testing kits and people who can
order testing kids over the Internet or
take testing hits home from pharmacies
as they're purchased and they collect
the sample at home and then it's sent to
a laboratory for analysis I think the
the positives of these are that the
increasing use suggests that people are
accessing these tests who perhaps aren't
accessing other or testing in other
sites and that's great if we reach more
of the population I think the downside
is it can be applied to the the risk of
contamination and not collecting the
samples but that can also happen in
clinics I mean I think that we need to
be really tested yes about the way that
we collect any specimen for and that
analysis because you know they are so
sensitive they can pick up some
contamination in samples and it's
impossible to tell if it came from the
patient or the surface in the clinic
where the swab was accidentally put and
so I think that having really clear
instructions for both clinical staff and
for patients about how to collect the
device how to collect the specimen and
how to use the devices in a way that
means you get the best specimens for the
laboratory and you know it doesn't
contain anything that it shouldn't but I
think that that's probably the biggest
issue or sometimes you know people
accessing tests perhaps that where they
think that they just by doing a test
that they're testing for everything that
perhaps they should be tested for but
clearly depending on somebody's sexual
history there may be other things that
are indicated for those patients and so
sometimes somebody just doing a test of
time they may think that that's all they
need but in if they came to a clinic
like ours we might identify some other
issues that we felt were really
important and they can't always be met
by home sampling
thank you looks like we have time for
one more question if we recommended to
test for trichomonas vaginalis in males
um recommendations often based on
evidence in terms of okay what rule why
should we test for an infection if
someone hasn't got symptoms or isn't
complaining of it therefore is there any
value in testing for it and treating it
in trichomonas it's an interesting
infection because men are probably only
transiently infected in a lot of cases
and women tend to be the reservoir of
infection in terms of their they have
long-standing infection which may be
symptomatic or asymptomatic and men
we've tried to - they would usually get
your ether infection which may cause a
discharge or dysuria or may be
asymptomatic and without testing and
treatment a lot of men would resolve
their infections but they may have been
infection long enough to pass it on to
another partner so if you've got a
population where there's a high rate of
trachomatis I think it's really
important to try to test men as well
because men are probably the vectors of
infection and I think if you can
identify their infections and treat them
effectively and also through partner
notification try to access as many
partners as possible who may have the
infection as well then I think that's
the best way to go is try to learn as
infection but I think you really rely on
that testing in men because in our
experience wet mount microscopy for
tractor motor sin in men has really
quite a low sensitivity I would like to
once again thank dr. white for his
presentation do you have any final
comments
now look I hope people tuned in I think
that STI is globally a really really
important issue that often don't get the
press and get the attention and if
there's any laboratory staff out there
keep up the good work and keep fighting
the good fight because we rely so much
on people that work in laboratories and
not all clinicians are as interested in
lab stuff as I am but you know we
couldn't do the the work that we do
without all of the laboratory staff and
all of those very clever essays that
give us all the results and so thanks
again to all the people who work in the
field thanks to Abbott for allowing this
presentation to take place and for their
ongoing commitment to diagnosing STI s
as well thank you and I'd like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration we would like to
thank our sponsor Abbott molecular for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on-demand
through july 2019 lab routes will alert
you via email when it's available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event until next
time goodbye